yes listen Stassi I start the pieces
thing to go I need you to step back and
allow me to handle this my first
priority is my daughter
and Mitchum deodorant and your best
man's name is BIC Mitchum well if your
best friend was named Jemima Colgate I
bet you wouldn't use log cabin syrup or
Aquafresh toothpaste would you
that was amazing dad you're beautiful
you know that oh no I'm amazing sweet
natural sexy so sexy that these guys
were civilians six months ago let's
coach him up I'll show them how team
guys do it I'll live the unit on the
street no I can't do that we need you on
overwatch come on if I'm on the street
mark I can lose the house is the
deadliest job here man you got some sort
of Savior complex I just want to get the
bad guys but if I can't see him I can't
shoot like all these guys I know your
name they feel invincible with you up
there they're not they are if they think
they are don't you just keep banging on
the long gun what these dogs sniff out
Zarqawi